GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO THE
FIRST MEETING OF THE- CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY AUSTIN YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE- AUDIO
ECHO OR FEEDBACK BURKE BEFORE WE
GET TO THESE HEARING I LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR THE
SIX VICTIMS OF SATURDAY'S
NIGHT'S TRAGIC SHOOTING INCIDENT
IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO SO WITH
THAT LET'S TAKE A MOMENT. OF
SILENCE.
THANK YOU. WE ALSO SEE WE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE SACRAMENTO CITY
FIRE DEPARTMENT WHAT THIS TODAY
SO LET ME ALSO THANK YOU FOR
MUCH MUCH BUT MUST HAVE BEEN A
LONG AND SAD NIGHT FOR YOUR
DEPARTMENT THE COMMUNITY THE
NURSES THE DOCTORS THAT ARE
TREATING THE TWELVE WOUNDED IN
OUR AREA HOSPITALS WE'RE TRULY
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. RESTAURANT
TODAY'S AGENDA REMIND EVERYONE
OF THE GROUND RULES FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. TO SEEK TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO WE
CAN HAVE PERFECT OF
DELIBERATIONS AND DECISIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER FACILITATE
THESE GOALS WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT OF DESTRUCTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
C. NG TH. AT TODAY'S HEARING
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM
THOSE IN THE ROOM AND THOSE
CALLING ON THE PHONE. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING BY CALLING. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE PIN
NUMBER IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR FOUR FOUR. CAN ALSO VISIT
THE COLLEGE WEBSITE AT EIGHT AM
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
FIRST OF QUORUM CIRCULAR ADULT
WE HAVE A QUORUM. WHAT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A CONCERT GOING TO
START AND SUBCOMMITTEE. SO THE
FIRST BILL WE HAVE ON TODAY'S
AGENDA IS AB SIXTEEN FORTY EIGHT
MAIENSCHEIN AND I SEE HIM HERE.
SO WITH THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
CAN START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MISTER MEMBERS IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES OF
HISTORIC PROPORTION DEVASTATING
BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THIS MANY
ANIMALS ARE LEFT BEHIND IN THE
RUSH TO EVACUATE. THESE
DISASTERS TRAGICALLY HIGHLIGHT
THE SERIOUS NEED FOR PREPARING
AND EXECUTING EVACUATION PLANS
FOR ANIMALS SOME COUNTIES
REQUIRE ANIMAL OWNERS WHO OWN
OVER A SPECIFIED NUMBER OF DOGS
OR CATS TO OBTAIN A KENNEL
PERMIT. AB SIXTEEN FORTY IT
WOULD ENSURE THESE COUNTIES
REQUIRE THE PERMIT HONORED TO
CREATE SUBMIT AN ANIMAL NATURAL
DISASTER EVACUATION PLAN THIS
BILL WOULD HELP SAVE THE LIVES
OF MANY ANIMALS DURING WILDFIRES
AND OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS
WHILE ALSO SAVING FIRST
RESPONDERS TIME AND RESOURCES.
WITH ME ON THE LINE I HAVE JUDY
MAN COUP SO ON BEHALF OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION ENGINE
AND OUT FROM MICKELSON FOUND
ANIMALS. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE THE
FOLLOWING. WE DO ALL WITNESSES
HAVE A VIOLIN OUR LINES ARE OPEN
. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
RODRIGUEZ AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JUDY MAN COULD GO FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
IN LEGISLATION ACROSS CONSERVE
AB FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT. WHEN I
MOVED TO LAGUNA BEACH DECADES
AGO I HAD MORE COMPANION ANIMALS
THE NOBLE PULLED ONE THAT
ALLOWED WITH THAT NUMBER OF
ANIMALS WHAT DO NOT BEACH
REQUIRED ME TO GET A KENNEL
PERMIT. WHICH FIFTY ELATED I
PAID IT PERMITS PETER THEM ALLOW
THEM TO INSPECT THE PROPERTY AND
THAT I HAD TO HAVE AN EVACUATION
PLAN AT FIRST I DID NOT KNOW
WHAT AN EVACUATION PLAN REALLY
MEANT IT AND MY CIRCUMSTANCE.
BUT IN TALKING TO THE ANIMAL
CONTROL OFFICERS THAT THE CITY
WHO ISSUED THE PERMIT I
UNDERSTOOD THAT I NEEDED WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO GET MY ANIMALS OUT
SAFELY AND QUICKLY IN CASE OF A
NATURAL DISASTER. WHICH MEANT
FOR ME HAVING THE PROPER NUMBER
OF YOURS AND A VEHICLE LARGE
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO TRANSPORT
THEM IT. UPON MY NEXT INSPECTION
I SHOW THEM I HAD PUT ALL OF IT
AND FIGHT. AND UNFORTUNATELY
SINCE THEN I HAVE INDEED AT THE
FOOT OF THE BACKED AWAY FROM
PLANS INTO ACTION WHEN FIRE HAS
STRUCK IN A CANYON ADJACENT TO
ME I AM GRATEFUL THEY READY MADE. PERFECTION OF THAT.
REQUIREMENT THIRD MIGHT COME AND
GOING TO BE. WELL FORGET AND DID
- SEND IN A SUPPORT LETTER NOW
ARE. HAS THE AROUND FIRE SEASON
IT IS THEM. THAT ALL OF YOUR-
RECALL REQUIRE ABOUT. PLAN AS A
CONDITION FOR A KENNEL PERMIT.
LAW TO HELP FACILITATE MOOD OF
ACTIVATION WHICH WILL SAVE THE
LIVES OF FAMILIES ANIMALS AND
ARE MOST IMPORTANT FIRST RESPOND
OR- WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU OPERATE WE HAVE
ONE MORE PERSON IN SUPPORT. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON- DISMEMBERED BY
NEIGHBORS NOT THAT BUT THE
NATIONAL FOR. IN DIRECTOR FOR
MICHAEL FLYNN FOUND OUT ABOUT
FOUNDATION BUT PREVIOUSLY TO
THAT I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FRONT STREET ANIMAL SHELTER
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
DESPITE CALIFORNIA GREAT BEAUTY
HOW BUDGET RESOURCES WERE WORTH
STATE BUT CLAYTON WITH THE
RAVAGES OF FIRE. CURRENTLY CAL
FIRED UNITED STATES FOREST
SERVICE REPORT OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND FIRED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR AND THE
IMPACT OF THE MARKET HE'S AFFECT
BOTH HUMAN AND ANIMAL LIFE. AND
GIVEN THAT WE KNOW WITH FOR THE
NEXT EVACUATION ORDERS HAVE BEEN
THAT ADVANCE PREPARATION TO
INCLUDE EVACUATION PLANS FOR OUR
FOUR LEGGED FRIENDS CRITICAL. AB
SIXTEEN FORTY EIGHT WILL REQUIRE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO OBTAIN
EVACUATION PLANS WHEN ISSUING
KNNEL PERMIT. IT WOULD START
AND IT'S A VERY GOOD START IN
THE COURSE OF MY CAREER I CAN'T
TELL THE NUMBER OF TIMES ARE OUT
OF A PATROL OFFICER AND KENNEL
STAFF WILL LOOK OUT TO OTHER
AGENCIES IN ORDER TO HELP
MITIGATE THE ANIMALS THAT ARE
LEFT BEHIND. INCLUDING AN
EVACUATION PLAN IN IT IN AN
ALREADY EXISTING PERMITTING
PROCESS OF THE POTENTIAL TO
EXPONENTIALLY REDUCE THE BURDEN
ON ANIMAL CONTROL AGENCIES FIRST
RESPONDERS BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF ANIMALS
THAT SUFFER AND OFTEN DIE AS A
RESULT. IN THE PAST SEVERAL
WEEKS I REALLY PRIVILEGED TO
PARTICIPATE YOU CONVERSATIONS
WITH COLLEAGUES THAT ARE WORKING
IN UKRAINE AND THEY'RE BROWN BE
COUNTRIES AND ALLOW UKRAINE MAY
BE AN EXTREME EXAMPLE OF WHAT
COULD GO WRONG IT'S EVIDENT THAT
ADVANCE PLANNING WITH REGARD TO
ANIMAL EVACUATION IN THE
HISTOPATHOLOGY. HELP EASE THE
BURDEN FOR MANY OF US PET OWNERS
IN THE CRANE WE MUST TAKE THE
LESSONS EVEN FOR NEXT WEEK'S
SPRING SITUATION- IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE AND THEIR
ANIMALS ARE PROTECTED TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY DURING
EMERGENCIES AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO SUPPORT SB SIXTEEN FORTY
EIGHT AND THAT I HOPE THAT. YOU
WILL AS WELL THANK YOU. THE YOU
WITHOUT AND FOR GOING FOR AND
LIKE WE HAVE A SO. CAN CALDERON
STARK. RODRIGUEZ THEY ARE TOUGH
THERE. ARE YORKERS. CALDERON
GREAT. WALDRON FORD. QUORUM IS
PRESENT THANK YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
THANK YOUS OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM OR ON PHONE THEY WERE LIKE
TO SPEAK CONSERVE. OPERATORS
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE'S BEEN
SUPPORT. THE BOOK A PUBLIC TO A
VOICE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO COULD NOT ALREADY DONE
SO OPERATIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
ONE IS CALLED STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION POSITION.
WORKFORCE COUPLE LINE NUMBER
FIFTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE
FIFTY ONE OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN YOU COULD OPEN
SUPPORT YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
COMMENT BUT A- MAYBE A MINUTE
OKAY ONE FIFTEEN IS DROPPED AND
YOU. I WILL NOT A LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE OH AND PLEASE JOIN
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CARDMEMBER KAREN LYING UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ANIMAL SHELTERS AND SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON THANK YOU. THANKS
NUMBER THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE
GOING PLATES. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS CALL HOLLY ABOUT HALF
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH IN
SUPPORT. ONE ELEVEN YOUR NEXT
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JULIANA TAIWO ON BEHALF
AND SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT. MEXICO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY AIRLINES OPEN
GO AND PUTS. ONE SEVENTY NUMBERS
BUT THE PRESIDENT ELECT ANOTHER
FRESNO YOU SEE UP FOR END UP
WITH A. MISTER CHEROKEE WAS NOT
CLEAR THANK YOU WHAT THAT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
OPERATORS ARE AND ONE ON THE
LINE REGARDING OPPOSITION. FOR
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PLEASE. FOR SURE WE HAVE NOBODY
QUEUED UP FOR ABOUT FOR
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
NOTES BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
KELLY MOTION WALDRON SECONDS. OF
A SIMILAR QUESTION ONE. YEAH
THANKS FOR BEING THE BILL FORD
AND THE REASON I'M SAYING THAT
IS THAT I'VE BEEN- INVOLVED WAY
TOO MANY FIRES. AND I HADN'T
THOUGHT OF WHEN I FIRST WALKED
IN THIS BUILDING SIX YEARS AGO
OR FIVE. ZERO ABOUT THE ANIMALS
AND HOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE BACK. AND BECAUSE THEY ARE
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR. A SUMMER WALDRON
THANK YOU ONE TO THINK THEY ARE
OR FOR BRING THIS PHONE- YOU
MIGHT RECALL IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WE HAVE THE LILAC FIRE. THAT WAS
IN MY DISTRICT IN BONSALL
FALLBROOK AREA. AND EVEN THOUGH
IT WASN'T A HUGE FIRE ON THE
SCALE OF THINGS IT WAS ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND ACRES IT DID.
BURNED A HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
STRUCTURES I'M ONE OF THOSE WAS
A THOROUGHBRED- TRAINING
FACILITY. WHICH FIFTY TWO HORSES
DIED IN THEIR STALLS BECAUSE
PEOPLE CAN GET THEM OUT THERE
WERE TRAILERS LINED UP TRYING TO
GET IN AND WITHOUT THE PLAN. IT
WAS DEVASTATING SO YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE THINGS WE VOWED THAT WE
WILL WORK ON AND CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IS HOW DO WE GET LIVE
STOCK OUT. IN TIME AND QUICKLY
SO THIS IS A GOOD STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION AND EDUCATING PEOPLE
HOPEFULLY HAVE A STATEWIDE-
REACH ANNA UNSPORTING BILL.
THANKS VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BURKE
REMEMBERS. IN WITH THAT THANK
YOU- I WOULD LIKE- THERE IS-
ANOTHER QUESTION COMMENTS I DO
LIKE THE BILL I THINK IS GREAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND
WITHOUT- WE HAVE A MOTION EFFECT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE I TO I LIKE MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. I REPRESENTED-
WHEN I WAS ON SAN DIEGO CITY
COUNCIL WE HAD TO BE TWO MAJOR
FIRES IN SAN DIEGO 200-032-0007
ST WAS YOU KNOW OVER THERE
WASN'T THAT AT THAT TIME YOU
KNOW IS THAT THERE WAS- A LACK
OF EDUCATION AND GETTING PEOPLE
OUT SO ANIMALS WERE CERTAINLY
SECONDARY TO THAT AND- NOW WE
KNOW WITH FIRES BECOMING REALLY
ALMOST A YEARLY OCCURRENCE-
MAJOR FIRES BECOMING A YEARLY
OCCURRENCE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
TO HAVE AN EVAC WHICH PLAN FOR
ANIMALS OF ALL SIZE OR THE LARGE
ANIMALS WHO CAN INTERFERE WITH
RESPOND OR IS OR COURSE MARMOSET
THAT FAMILIES AND PEOPLE REALLY
CARE ABOUT MORE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RESCUED AND SAFE TO
SELL- REALLY PROFIT FROM THIS
BILL AND- I APPRECIATE. THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITH THAT SIR.
CALDERON MOTION IS DUE PASS A
COMMITTEE ON APPROVED ROGER ALL
RIGHT RODRIGUEZ I SEYARTO
SEYARTO I AYE YOUR CURRY ARE
YOUR CURRY I CALDERON CALDERON
AYE GRAY. WALDRON WALDRON AYE
WARD. WITH FIVE IS THE BILLS OUT
THE RESULT THANK YOU MISTER. M.
BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER I WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND SINCE WE HAVE A
CORE OF COMMERCE DOLLARS START
WITH OUR CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS WE HAVE
A V. SIXTEEN SIX SIXTEEN SIXTY
FOUR GABBRO COMMITTEE AMONG
HUMANS REGARDING CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
IN AB NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR
RODRIGUEZ OPERATION CAL ONLY HAS
TO ESTABLISH A BROADBAND
COMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM FOR
PROGRAMS. FEDERAL MOTION A
SECOND MOTION BY MISS WALDRON
SECOND BY MYSTERY. I BELIEVE FOR
OKAY. FOR SO AT THAT CALL THE
CALL CENTER CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION FOR A V. SIXTEEN SIXTY
FOUR IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND FOR AB NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR DO COST TO
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SEE ARE TO START OUT
I AND YOUR CREE. A YEAR CURRY I
CALDERON CALDERON AYE GRAY.
WALDRON WALDRON I TOWARD. FIVE
EYES ARE LOOKS LIKE CONSENT IS
OUT FOR NEXT BELIEVE I SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY. AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETEEN. GEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MERKLEY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY VERY GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT BY AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN THE RURAL CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE ACT. AND- I WANT
TO SAY I VIEW THIS IS A BILL TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA FUNCTION AS
AN ENTIRE STATE. BIKE KNOWLEDGE
IN THE SPECIAL PROBLEMS OF SOME
OF OUR MORE RURAL COUNTIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED WHICH INCLUDE
DECLINING POPULATIONS. AND AND
SO TO ME THIS IS ACTUALLY A
FUNDING PROGRAM FOR A BILL TO
SUPPORT PRIMARILY COUNTIES UNDER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND. SO THAT
ARE THERE LOCAL OFFICIALS
CONCEPTO GETS FOR THINGS ARE
NEEDED IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND
THE STATE WILL STEP UP TO HELP
FUND THE ACT- SO I VIEW IT AS
KIND OF TRYING TO FUNCTION AS
ONE BIG STATE- BUT LET ME
CONTINUE LET ME. PROCEED WITH MY
STATEMENT HAVING SAID THAT. I DO
KNOW THIS WOULD BE GOOD FOR THE
GREAT STATED. THE PEOPLE AGREE
SENATE JEFFERSON DO USE THAT
EXPRESSION- WHICH IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW WELL- RECENT
DATA FOR THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
DEMOGRAPHICS UNIT SHOWS THAT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. ONLY EIGHT OUT
OF OUR FIFTY COUNTIES EITHER HAD
NO POPULATION GROWTH OR
EXPERIENCE POPULATION LOSS
WHETHER FROM LACK OF ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY OR MOVES CAUSED BY
WILD FLOWERS WHEN CITIES AND
COUNTIES LOSE RESIDENTS AND
THEIR TAX BASE THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCE AVAILABLE PAY FOR LOCAL
UPKEEP SUFFERS. COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS FOR SERVER HIGHLIGHT
LOCAL CULTURE AS WELL AS PROVIDE
IN A NUMBER OF JUST SATURATED
FUNCTIONS INCLUDING SHELTER IN
PLACE ARE CONSISTENTLY
UNDERFUNDED AND IN DISREPAIR. AW
I REPRESENT RANCHO MURIETA WHICH
IS ON THE EASTERN EDGE OF SECOND
A COUNTY DOWN THE JACKSON
HIGHWAY AND THE MOST LOGICAL SAY
SPOT THE GOAL IS TO RUN UP THE
HILL TO THE AMADOR COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS JUST BE ON PLYMOUTH
ABOUT TWELVE MILES AWAY. LOCAL
ROADS MAINTAINED BY COUNCILS
HAVE YEARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WHICH AFFECT
POTENTIAL EVACUATION ROUTE FOR
RESIDENTS. AS WELL AS CRITICAL
ACCESS FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
SMALL TOWNS AND UNINCORPORATED
ERRORS HAVE NO FUNDING MECHANISM
TO REPAIR OR BRING UP TO CODE
HISTORICALLY STABLE BUILT
SIGNIFICANT BUILDINGS FOR THE
COMMUNITY- AND- ENJOY. HISTORIC
RANGES OR OTHER SORTS OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE A VITAL PART
OF LOCAL HISTORY. AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETEEN THE RURAL
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE ACT
APPROPRIATES ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDS FOR GRANTS TO SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. INDEPENDENT FIRE
DISTRICT SO THERE I'M REALLY
TALKING VOLUNTEER TYPE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE THEY'LL HAVE
LIMITED MEANS LIKE HAROLD
CALIFORNIA OR WILL IN CALIFORNIA
HELLO THERE AND SECOND COUNTY
BUT THEY ILLUSTRATE THE IDEA. R.
OR COUNTIES WITH POPULATIONS
LESS THAN THREE THOUSAND FOR
RURAL INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
INCLUDING DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
DISASTER RECOVERY HIGHWAY OR
STREET REPAIR FOR EVACUATION
ROUTES. THE FUNDS WILL BE
OVERSEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK THE SO CALLED
HIGH BANK. SO IN THAT SENSE THIS
IS NOT TRYING TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL IS TAKEN AND A WELL
ESTABLISHED TRUCKS- IN FITTING
THIS INTO THAT STRUCTURE. ON
OFTENTIMES ARE IN OUR DISTRICTS
ARE PROJECTS TO BRING FORMAL
COVERS THE PHONE BUT TOO SMALL
TO DRAW DOWN STATE FEDERAL
MONIES. AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN
WILL HELP GET MONEY TO THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS- IN RURAL
PARTS. OF CALIFORNIA. ON AND I
DO UNDER. THAT JEFF NEAL ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNTIES PROBABLY
JOIN US ON THE PHONE AS A
WITNESS AND SUPPORT. STRUCTURE
DEFERRED TO HIM NOW. THANK YOU
SOME REMEMBER OPERATOR TO HAVE-
JR FROM THE LINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS JEFF
NEAL HERE. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. IT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY- WE SUPPORT THE BILL UP
FOR TWO. WHARTON REASONS FIRST
OF ALL DESPITE THE DECADE LONG
SURGEON STATE REVENUES MOST
COUNTIES HAVE HAD LACKLUSTER
GROWTH IN THEIR GENERAL PLANS IN
MOST COUNTIES THAT GENERAL FUND
REVENUES PER CAPITA ARE STILL
BELOW THE LEVELS THEY WERE AT
BEFORE THE GREAT RECESSION TO
RECESSION TO GO NOW BUT IN REAL
DOLLARS THIS PROBLEM IS MOST
PRONOUNCED IN SMALL COUNTIES. M.
PARTLY BECAUSE THE NEED FOR
GOVERNMENT SERVICE DOESN'T SCALE
DOWN PROPORTIONATELY WITH
POPULATION SIZE AND THE OTHER
REASON IS BECAUSE THE PHYSICAL
AND ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF
WILDFIRES AND OTHER DISASTERS
HAVE FALLEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
ON SMALL COUNTIES AND WILL
COMMUNITIES- IN ADDITION THIS
YEAR WE THINK ANOTHER. GREAT
REASON. FOR THIS BILL. INSTEAD
THAT CAPITAL OUTLAY EXPENDITURES
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE STATE
APPROPRIATION LIMIT- AND SO THIS
IS A GREAT TIME THIS YEAR IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE STATE TO
INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WILL PROVIDE A LONG TERM BENEFIT
TO THESE AREAS THAT. DO BEAR A
DISPROPORTIONATE. RISKING
DISPROPORTIONATE ECONOMIC
EFFECTS OF NATURAL DISASTERS-
AND THAT IN MANY CASES. HAVE
LACKLUSTER REVENUE GROWTH SO FOR
ALL THOSE REASONS NOTHING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLIES.
OFFERING THE BILL AND-
APPRECIATE YOUR I THOUGHT. THANK
YOU DIFFERENT- WITH THAT IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT. SHE NONE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LIKE
SPEAKING SUPPORT OPERATOR ANYONE
ON THE LINE. OPEN THE PHONE
BILLS OFFENSIVE HE LEADS BECAUSE
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINETEEN
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE. I HAVE
ONE FOR THE STATE AND I LIKE TO
MAKE WHEN IT'S CONVENIENT MISTER
CHAIR. MR WE HAVE NO RESPONSE IN
Q. THANK YOU MUCH- ST BERKELEY
JONATHAN. YEAH I WANT TO SAY
THAT- AS ON THE ANNEX PROJECT
WHICH I HAVE BEEN BUSY WITH-
WHICH REFLECTS OUR- PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS USE A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE THIS BILL
PROPOSED TO SPEND MONEY AROUND
THE STATE THE STATE'S STEPPING
UP TO FUND THIS I FAVOR THOSE
SORTS OF PROVISIONS I'M A LITTLE
UNCLEAR ON HOW TO SEE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK WORKS. BUT I
DO SUPPORT OF THE INCLUSION OF
LANGUAGE WHICH HAS BEEN BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION- BY OUR LABOR
PARTNERS I'VE INTEND TO WORK
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF IN THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
ON HOW YOU. DROPPED THAT
LANGUAGE INTO THE BILL. BUT TO
CLARIFY THAT DARES- AS YOU'VE
PROJECT PROCEED FOR PROJECTS
WOULD NOT OTHERWISE BE FUNDED
BUT FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH THESE FUNDS AVAILABLE THAT
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD PROVISION
AND OF COURSE I KNOW THAT MEANS
THAT THOSE DOLLARS WILL GET SPIN
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHAT THEY'RE
SPUR. LOCAL ECONOMIC ACTIVITY SO
I THINK IT'S ALL A BIG PART OF
THE STATE'S SUPPORT IN THE
ENTIRETY OF OUR STATE IS TO
HELP. KEEP ECONOMY IS HUMMING.
AND THIS TAKES DOLLAR CONSUMERS
WITH DOLLARS IN HER POCKET. SO I
THINK- IF THE PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE THOSE SORTS
OF FUNDS THEY WILL STILL GET A
LOCAL COLLEGE THAT'S A GOOD.
VISION AND THAT WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION TODAY AND I'M
ACTUALLY QUITE SUPPORTIVE OF IT.
OKAY THANK YOU- WITHOUT US OR
ANYONE IN THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION. ASSEMBLY WE HAVE
SOMEBODY COME FOR PROPOSITION.
FOUR HUNDRED. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIKE WEST WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL OR AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION WE APPRECIATE
THE DIALOGUE WITH THE MEMBER AND
HIS STAFF AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO INCLUDING PREVAILING
WAGE AND SKILLED IN TRAIN WHICH
ARE GRADUATES OF STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS OF THE
MEMBER STAFF HAS BEEN RECEPTIVE-
TO OUR DIALOGUE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CHANGE IN OUR
POSITION TO SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN PERSON HERE FOR
OPPOSITION. WHAT THAT WILL GO
OVER TO THE PHONES. OPERATORS
ARE ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION- IN OPPOSITION FOR
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN PRESS ONE
ZERO PLANS. MISTER TURNER
RESPONDENTS ARE QUEUING UP. OKAY
WITHOUT WILL BRING BACK TO
MEMBERS AND I BELIEVE THERE IS A
MOTION AND A SECOND RIGHT. AND
THE RECEIVER COVER I WAS
EMOTIONAL. OR EDLER CURRY WITH
THE MOTION HELLO THIS. ANY
QUESTIONS COMES BY. BY YOUR TWO
SEVEN A- THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND- YOU KNOW IT KIND OF
APPROACHES THIS. WE HAVE ALL
SORTS OF PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA
YEAH SOMETIMES WE TRY TO CREATE
THE SOLUTIONS FOR EVERYBODY TO
TRY TO APPLY TO THE DISTRICT
WHAT THIS DOES IS ALLOW THOSE
DISTRICTS. TO FIND AND IDENTIFY
THEIR OWN ISSUES AND SOLUTIONS
TO THOSE ISSUES. AND THEN
USUALLY THERE'S NO FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR IT SO THIS ALLOWS
THEM TO HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY
WHERE THEY CAN GET THE FUNDING
AND MAKE A PLAN THAT WORKS FOR
THEM- WHICH IS. A I THINK IT'S A
COMMENDABLE APPROACH. TO TRYING
TO ACTUALLY HELP AND MAKE A DENT
IN THESE- THESE FACILITIES
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS
ESPECIALLY FAIR GROUNDS AND
THINGS. THEY ARE THE SAFE REFUGE
AREAS THEY ARE THE BASE CAMP
AREAS FOR INCIDENT COMMAND
CENTERS FOR. ALL THESE AND IF
THEY ARE NOT WELL MAINTAINED AND-THERE IS ANOTHER BUILDING HERE
THAT HELP WITH BROADBAND IN
THOSE AREAS- THEN WE HAVE
SHORTAGES IN IN THOSE TYPE OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE DESPERATELY
NEEDED IN TIMES OF. OF CRISIS
AND DEBT SO- NEEDED VERY
COMMENDABLE- APPROACH TO- THE
THIS IN THIS ISSUE AND I- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING. THANK YOU SOME
MEMBERS THANK YOU ANY ONE ELSE
QUESTIONS CARRILLO. SO THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YEAH I WOULD JUST SAY
YOU KNOW I THINK IT IS A
FUNCTION OF STATE GOVERNMENT. TO
NOT ALWAYS SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM.
BUT TO FIND A WAY TO RELEASE
ENERGY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT. BECAUSE ACTUALLY WE
ARE ABLE TO RELEASE ENERGY AT
THE LOCAL. LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
MORE PEOPLE PUT THEIR SHOULDER
TO THE WHEEL MORE THINGS WILL
GET DONE. AND WILL BE VALUED
BECAUSE IT'S WHAT THEY
PRIORITIZED. SO I THINK FOR
HIGHLIGHTED THAT I DEFINITELY
THINK THIS IS A. I TO ME THAT
JUST MEANS. AREN'T THESE THE
SMALLER COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE
FORTUNATE THEY'RE PART OF A BIG
PROSPER STATE AND IT'S JUST
RIGHT FOR THE- FOR THE MORE- THE
AREAS WITH MORE RESOURCES TO
KIND OF FUNCTIONS ONE STATE. SO
I JUST THINK THIS IS SORT OF AN
EASY PURPOSE UNUM RELEASE OF
ENERGY BILL AND I REQUEST TRAVEL
. THANKS VERY MUCH I LOVE THIS
BILL AS WELL IT'S A THREAT TO
THE HOME OR PROTECT OUR FOLKS
WITH THAT WAS MOTION SECOND THE
MOTION TO PASS. TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JOBS ECONOMIC A NUMBER
DEVELOPMENT AND ECONOMY SECTOR
CALL THE ROLL. RODRIGUEZ HI
RODRIGUEZ AYE SECTOR AYE SECTOR
AYE AGIR CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
CALDERON. CALDERON I GRADE.
WALDRON WALDRON I WARNED. FIVE
IS THE BILLS OUT THANKS SIMILAR
HUMOR MOTION IS OUT. SO WITH
THAT WE DON'T HAVE RIVER SINCE
ALL GO AHEAD AND DO MY BILLS.
RIGHT RIGHT YEAH. ALL RIGHT NEXT
UP WE HAVE A BEAST TWENTY ONE
MISTER CHAIR WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR SIR YOUR
TOTAL CALIFORNIA IS A DISASTER
PRONE STATE. AND ENHANCING THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
TWO MAJOR DISASTERS AT THE SAME
TIME AS THE PRINT PARTY FOR ME.
IT IS NO SECRET THAT WORKS
EXPECT TO HAVE ANOTHER MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE ON THE SAN ANDREAS
FAULT. NUMBER NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR THAN OUR THREE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE AND THE DEATHS THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED. IF WE
HAD AN EARTHQUAKE OCCURRED
DURING THE HEIGHT OF OUR
PANDEMIC OUR MUTUAL AID TO AN
EMS SYSTEMS. BUT I'VE BEEN
OVERWHELMED. THIS BILL HAS THREE
MAJOR COMPONENTS. A FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION SEISMIC RETROFIT PROGRAM
TO PROTECT VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
IN THEIR HOMES. A FIFTY MILLION
EMS MUTUAL AID GRANT PROGRAMS TO
ENHANCE OUR MERCH MEDICAL SEARCH
CAPABILITIES. AT A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION LOCAL RESILIENCY
EMERGING PREPARERS AND MUTUAL
AID FUND. TO HELP OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS PREPARE FOR DISASTERS.
THIS LEGISLATION AS A WHOLE
WOULD HELP IMPROVE THE STATE OF
MUTUAL AID IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE.
CEMETERY IF DISASTER STRIKES AND
IT'S NOT TOO LATE. MY GET MY
BILL IS FOR THE FOR THE GOOD OF
TAXPAYERS FOR EVERY DOLLAR
INVESTED. INTO MITIGATION
COMMUNITIES YOUR SAVE SIX
DOLLARS DUE TO THE REDUCE FUTURE
LOSSES. THIS WILL ALSO GIVE
LOCAL ENTITIES THE FLEXIBILITY
PART TIES RESILIENCY AND
MITIGATION PROGRAMS TO ENSURE WE
MAXIMISE THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF OUR FUTURE DISASTER
VICTIMS. RESILIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE CRITICAL
HELPING PROTECT LIVES AND
LIVELIHOODS WERE DISASTER STRUCK
THE HARDEST FOR EXAMPLE CONSIDER
THE COST OF RETROFITTING. MULTI
FAMILY SOFT STORY HOUSING VERSUS
REPLACING THESE SAME STRUCTURES
THANK YOU. THE COSTA
RETROFITTING A UNIT IS
APPROXIMATELY 500-021-0000
VERSUS THE ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
REPLACE A HOUSING UNIT. AGAIN
THIS WALTARI SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS IN THE LONG RUN RESPECT
US FOR ABOUT. ASSEMBLY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ IF YOU
HAVE THREE WITNESSES. TALKING IN
SUPPORT YES THEY SHOULD BE IN
FOR ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY OF
THEM HERE IN PERSON WE DO HAVE
ONE FOR HONORABLY ON FROM OURS
IF WE DO WE HAVE ONE PERSON
COMING. YOU CAN COME UP. HI AND
DARBY KERNAN ON BEHALF OF
LEADING H. CALIFORNIA- IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO AB SEVENTY
TWENTY ONE FOR THE LONG TERM
CARE MUTUALLY PLAN. IT'S A
CRITICAL ISSUE TO MAKE SURE OUR
NURSING HOMES. HAVE A PLANNING
CAN GET PEOPLE OUT OF ANY NEW OR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS ARE ON THE
PHONE WITH MORE TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU RIGHT. THANK YOU I BELIEVE
WE HAD THREE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. THAT WERE EVAN
REES. RAY REARDON AND DON CHEN
SKI. SO DO WE HAVE ANY OF THEM
ON THE LINE. SEVEN REVIEWS HERE.
IS OUR PRIMARY WITNESS A LITTLE
SUPPORT. GO AHEAD. ALSO I DON'T
OKAY THANK YOU MY NAME IS HENRY
I'M A STRUCTURAL ENGINEER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NONPROFIT U. S. RESILIENCY
COUNCIL FOR A SPONSOR AND
SUPPORTER OF AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
ONE. USRC MISSION IS TO IMPROVE
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE THROUGH
ADVOCACY FOR MAKING BUILDINGS
MORE RESILIENT TO NATURAL
DISASTERS OUR GUIDING PRINCIPLE
IS ENGINEERING IN THE SERVICE OF
EQUITY THE ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
ECONOMY AND I BELIEVE THAT AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE IN
PARTICULAR THE PROVISION
APPROPRIATING FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
GRANT FUNDING TOWARDS THE
SEISMIC RETROFIT OF SOFT STORY
APARTMENT BUILDINGS IT'S
PERFECTLY WITH THAT DIED IN
PRINCIPLE I'D LIKE TO DESCRIBE
WHY. CALIFORNIA HAS AN ESTIMATED
A HUNDRED THOUSAND FIVE STORY
APARTMENT BUILDINGS WHICH ARE
PRONE TO COLLAPSE IN EARTHQUAKES
I NEXT UNREINFORCED BRICK
BUILDINGS THEY MAY BE THE MOST
DANGEROUS. OUTSIDE THE BUILDING
IN CALIFORNIA. LAPSE OF SOFT
STORY BUILDINGS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OF DEATHS IN NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE. ANYTHING MAY HOUSE
UPWARD OF TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
THESE TYPES OF BUILDINGS ARE
TYPICALLY THE EASIEST
SEISMICALLY RETROFIT. I THINK WE
ADDING STEEL FRAME FOR WHAT WILL
BE THE FIRST STORY PARKING AREA.
RECORD OPERATING FIVE TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT.
COMPARE THAT TO MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A TYPICALLY
COST TO BUILD ONE UNIT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE GOES TO THE HEART OF
EQUITY AND SO MANY OF THESE
BUILDINGS HOUSE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SENIORS
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES. I CAN THINK OF NO
OTHER WAY SEISMIC MITIGATION
FUNDS COULD BE BETTER TARGETED
TOWARDS SOCIALLY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THROUGH THE
RETROFITTING OF SOFT STORY
APARTMENT BUILDING. AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE ALSO HAS A DIRECT
IMPACT ON OUR MIND. GREENEST
BUILDING IS ONE THAT'S ALREADY
BUILT PRESERVING THE STRUCTURES
MEANS LEFT TO BRING IN LANDFILLS
REACHING TOXIC CHEMICALS INTO
OUR AIR WATER AND SOIL. AND LESS
CARBON PUT INTO THE ATMOSPHERE
REPLACING DESTROYED BUILDINGS
WITH NEW LAW. AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE WOULD ALSO PROTECT
OUR WORKFORCES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND PERSONAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES WILL
DESPERATELY NEED AFTER A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE. AND FINALLY AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE WOULD
CREATE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF GOOD
PAYING ENGINEERING A
CONSTRUCTION JOB THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THIS
LEGISLATION IN MY OPINION IT
WILL BE MORE GOOD FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAN ANY SEISMIC
LEGISLATION IN THE PAST. SEVENTY
FIVE YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MR SHIN SKI DOO EVAN
REESE. OR RAY REARDON ON THE
LINE. IT WAS DEFINITELY BACK GO
AHEAD MYSTERY. NO I JUST I JUST
- THE LONG I'M SORRY MYSTERIES
YOU DID YOU JUST SPOKE SO IT'S
RAY REARDON OR DOWN CHEN SKI.
YOU CAN HEAR ME. YES GO AHEAD
SIR. I THANK YOU THANK YOU
AUDIBLE COMMITTEE CHAIRED
MEMBERS OF THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE PANEL SO
THOSE ATTENDING ON THE PHONE
TODAY I THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RETREATS FROM SPONSORING THIS
LEGISLATION IS SO CRITICAL TO
HELPING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT DISASTER.
AFTERNOON I AM READY RIORDAN
FROM THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE. FOR THIRTY SIX
YEARS I'VE HAD THE GREAT
OPPORTUNITY OF SERVING AS AN
EMERGENCY MANAGER RESPONDING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL STATE LEVEL
FEDERAL AND SPECIAL DISTRICT
LEVEL. ON THE IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE AND CURRENT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR. OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS OVER SIX HUNDRED
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE EMERGENCY
MANAGERS. I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE. EIGHT
FOR ONE WILSHIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES. TO BUILD COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE STRIKE THE MITIGATION
PROGRAMS UPDATE FACILITIES AND
EQUIPMENT. AND ENHANCE MUTUAL
AID PROGRAMS. CAL WE HAVE TO
FEEL BOTH AGREE THAT THE FACTORS
ARE LOCAL. LOCAL POLICE FIRE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THE FIRST
TO RESPOND TO AND THE CRITICAL
DECISIONS. LIKE AWARDING A
WARNING. FOR THE FIRST TO THE
PUBLIC LOOKS FOR AN EXPECTED FOR
NATION DECISION TO PICK
COMMITTEE. FOCUS FOCUS PUT YOUR
SHIP. THE LAST THREE CAL EXPERT
TWENTY STATE. DISASTERS THESE
INCLUDED THE ATMOSPHERIC RIVER
STORMS FLOODS DROUGHT THE
ENORMOUS WILDLAND FIRES THE
COACH MILLIONS OF ACRES. WE NEED
TO IMPROVE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CAPABILITIES TO PREPARE AND
RESPOND TO FUTURE EMERGENCIES.
AND NOT FOCUSING ALASKA MIRCHI.
WE NEED TO ENHANCE READINESS
BEFORE THE NEXT QUICKER QUICK.
AFTER THE RECORDING MORE
FREQUENTLY WITH GREATER VERACITY
IN THE FUNDING STREAMS AVAILABLE
THROUGH CALORIES FEED THE TO
SUPPORT LOCAL EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS FOR INSUFFICIENT.
AND THAT THE CHAIR DIDN'T
MENTION IF YOU A PUBLICATIONS
EVERY ONE DOLLAR INVESTED IN
PREPAREDNESS AND MITIGATION
SAVES SIX DOLLARS RECOVERY.
LET'S INVEST AHEAD OF THE NEXT
DISASTER CAN REDUCE THE IMPACTS
I APPRECIATE THE APPRECIATE YOUR
ABLE. I THANK YOU MR RIORDAN AND
THEN MISTER SHOULDN'T SCARE YOU
THERE AND AVAILABLE. WE DON'T
SHOW MISTER SINCE HE DIALED IN
AS A WITNESS INSTRUCTIONS KEY IF
YOU ARE LISTENING PLEASE PRESS
STAR ZERO AND AN OPERATOR WILL
GET THE NAME OF BRING YOU UP.
THOMAS ALL RIGHT IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE DO NOT HAVE A MISTER SHINSEKI
SO WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK- TO ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
THAT WE ALREADY HAD ONE PERSON
COME UP- SO SHE NEED NOT TO COME
UP AGAIN- THAT AS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS. MEASURE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHRIS COST ON YOUR OWN
SACRAMENTO FIRE DEPARTMENT. WE
COULD SUPPORT THIS WITH AN AYE
VOTE AND WE SAW THE DISASTROUS.
DISASTROUS EFFECTS THAT. ARE THE
SOFT STORY BUILDINGS HAD DURING
THE LOMA PRIETA EARTHQUAKE AND
ANY FUTURE. AMENDMENTS TO
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION WILL HELP
US OUT AND WE WOULD ALSO KEEP US
FROM- DIVERTING OUR RESOURCES
THAT ARE VALUABLE IN ANY TYPE OF
INCIDENT LIKE THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR HI MISTER OPERATOR
EIGHTEEN T. CAN WE GO TO LINES
AND OPEN THE LINES UP FOR
ANYBODY THAT HIS IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE MEMBER PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AFTER THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE FROM AND YOUR- SUPPORT
BALK. ORDERED WE DO HAVE
RESTRICTIONS COULD NOT. STE
THANK YOU RONALD YOU CAN JUST
TAKE A COUPLE OF MINUTES TO
PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY WE
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MY APOLOGIES
FOR COMING IN THE WRONG DOOR-
DIED YEAH I BOUGHT THIS ADOPTION
SPEAKER ON BEHALF THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA- WE COULD WE WOULD
CERTAINLY AKIO ALL OF THE POINT-
MADE BY THE BILL'S SPONSOR- WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS- I AGREED
THAT. WE WOULD AGREE IT LOOKS TO
BE- BOLD ENOUGH TO KIND OF COVER
BOTH THE BREADTH AND THE DEPTH
OF THE POPEMOBILE BE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- MISTER WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP WILL.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORK ON THE BILL
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR OR
WOULD YOU GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
LINES FOR- ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO
ADD ON. THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRPERSON PORT OF THE B.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE PRESS. ONE
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE GOING OUT TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX ONE
THIRTY SIX FOR ATHLETES. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER CAPETOWN
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND
APARTMENTS LOCATION OF GREATER
LA IN STRONG SUPPORT. AN EXTRA
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE TWENTY
GO AND- THIS IS KEVIN BURKE I'M
THE CEO OF PARADISE VALLEY IN
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE MUTUAL AID PLAN
FOR LONG TERM CARE- IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS WE'VE EXPERIENCED
WILDFIRES WHICH- RESULTED IN
FULL EVACUATION OF MY COMMUNITY.
I HAD TO MOVE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY RESIDENTS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY LOW LIGHTENING COMPLEX
PLAYER I HAD FIFTEEN MINUTES
NOICE FOR THAT- EVACUATION. WE
ENDED UP MOVING RESIDENTS FROM
FAIRFIELD TO SACRAMENTO DURING
THAT FIRE. AND AS A RESULT IT
TOOK US NEARLY TWENTY EIGHT
HOURS TO RESUME OPERATIONS.
THANK YOU MY EXPERIENCE WITH SO
ARE YOU PLANNING ON SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE. AND WE JUST NEED IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. SUPPORT
OKAY SO YOU SUPPORT SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE. CORRECT THANK YOU
SIR NEXT BIGGER PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NEXT WE GOT A LINE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT TANGO
AT SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS BRADY GARDEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT RELY
NUMBER NINETEEN GOING TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS CONNOR SWEENEY
CALLING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FCILITIES
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU. AND WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIR THE QUEUE IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T THINK WE DO
SO ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD AND EXPRESS THAT. AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ANYBODY A
SPRING TO THEIR FEET SO WE WILL
GO TO THE ALLIANCE EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN THE LINE
FOR ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. ONCE
AGAIN PROPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO
POINTS. I MISTER CHIRLA OR NOT
RESPONDENTS QUEUING UP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S BRING BACK OUR
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. I HAVE A MOTION BY AGUILAR
CURRY. AND A SECOND BY A
CALDERON. THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS MR RODRIGUEZ WHO YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT US FOR
ABOUT THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ VERY GOOD BILL- MUCH
NEEDED THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND- I REMEMBER THE LOMA
PRIETA. EARTHQUAKE THE MOST.
PROMINENT PICTURE ON THE SCREEN
WAS THE COLLAPSE BUILDING OF. OF
THIS FIRST STORY BEING CRUSHED
BY THE SECOND THIRD STORY TO THE
BUILDING WE HAVE A LOT OF THOSE
TYPE OF BUILDINGS AROUND THEY
NEED THEY NEED TO ADDRESS SO
THIS WILL HELP ADDRESS THIS. SO
WITH THAT- YOU GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
A COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ I SEYARTO
ALL RIGHT SIR SO I HAVE YOUR
CREE. ARE YOUR CURRY I CALDERON
CALDERON I GRADE. WALDRON
WALDRON I WARNED FORD FIVE RIGHT
IS THAT BILL IS OUT AND ON ITS
WAY TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WE WANT TO GO
AHEAD WITH THE SECOND BILL WE
HAVE OUR OTHER AUTHOR IS IN THE
BUILDING. WHEN WE THINK YOU'RE
UP THERE ALREADY MR RODRIGUEZ MY
TO GO AHEAD AND- WHICH AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY. THANK YOU
VICE CHAIR SURCHARGE TO
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT ON THIS ISSUE. THE
PROBLEM OF EXTENT OF ALL TIMES
HAS BEEN A PROBLEM FOR DECADES
AS YOU KNOW WHAT TIME OCCURS
WHEN AN AMBULANCE ARRIVED AT A
HOSPITAL. AND IS FORCED TO WAIT
FOR THE HOSPITAL TO ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY OF CARE FOR
PATIENTS. WHAT TIMES RESULT IN
ULTIMATELY. UNTIMELY CARE FOR
PATIENTS EXPERIENCING AND MERCY.
AND PREVENTS I'M WITH PERSONNEL
FROM RESPONDING TO OTHER
EMERGENCIES. I THINK YOU ALL
KNOW THAT SERVED. AS THE FIRST
RESPOND FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
AND I REMEMBER WORKING ONE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR SHIFT AND I
WAITED FOR OVER TWELVE HOURS AT
A HOSPITAL TO TRANSFER PATIENTS
. LET ME BE CLEAR EXTENSIVE WHAT
TIMES ARE NOT GOOD FOR THE
PATIENT. THEY ARE NOT GOOD FOR
THE AMBULANCE CREW. IN THE WATER
UNDER CERTAINLY NOT GOOD FOR
SOMEONE MAKING AN URGENT NINE
ONE ONE CALL FOR MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE. WHEN THERE ISN'T AN
ALBUM IT'S AVAILABLE TO
DISPATCH. EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS
COMMITTEE HOLD HELD AN
OVERSIGHT. HEARING ON WHAT
TIMES. WE HAVE SINCE. BEEN
LEADING DELIBERATIONS BETWEEN
THE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY. TO IDENTIFY
BOTH SHORT AND LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS. I WAS AS A RESULT OF
MY HEARINGS AND SUBSEQUENT
MEETINGS I AM PLEASED TO SEE
ADDITIONAL YOU MUST RESOURCES.
DEPLOYED TO HOSPITAL TO HELP
TRANSFER STABLE PATIENTS. FROM
MEMBERS OF TO MERGING
APARTMENTS. WELL THIS IS A GOOD
OUTCOME IN THE SHORT TERM A
REMAKE A MINUTE TO IMPLEMENTING
OTHER SOLUTIONS. TO ENSURE
AMBULANCES EMTS AND PARAMEDICS
ARE ONLY AVAILABLE. TO RESPOND
TO NUMBER ONE CALLS. I SHOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT LARGE OF THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED A. B. TWELVE
TWENTY NINE. WHICH AT WHICH
WOULD HAVE DIRECTED MS- TO
IMMEDIATELY CONVENE A TASK FORCE
OF ALL TIMES. HE THOUGH THIS
BILL WASN'T. I WAS PLEASED TO
SEE M. SUCH CONVENE A ONE TIME
TASK FORCE. ACCORDING TO MS OF
THE TASK FORCE WERE ISSUED A
REPORT BY LATE APRIL. FOR BOTH
SHORT AND LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. I
JUST PRINT AMENDED THIS BILL
PERFECT RECOMMENDATION BROUGHT
FORTH BY THIS TASK FORCE.
ADDITION I THINK WE MUST BE
PREPARED TO MAKE. A
COMPREHENSIVE AND BALANCED
APPROACH. WE CAN SOLVE THIS ON
THE BACKS OF EMTS AND PARAMEDICS
ALONE. WILL HAVE TO HAVE A
MECHANISM IN PLACE TO HOLD
HOSPITALS ACCOUNTABLE FOR DELAYS
REGARDLESS OF THE COSTS. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS THIS BILL SHOULD
BE VIEWED AS A WORK IN PROGRESS
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH EVERYONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES. THE FIRST ONE WILL BE
ON THE PHONE. CHIEF RATE GUY
FROM ONTARIO FIRE. TWEET MISTER
OPERATED WE HAVE MISTER DECKER
CHEESECAKE ON THE PHONE. CHU
THANK YOUR LINE IS OPEN BECAUSE
SEATS ARE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU GERMAN RODRIGUEZ
SOME MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
FOR THIS OPPORTUNISTIC TODAY MY
NAME IS FOR A GUY I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY. AS THE
PRESENT ACCOUNTS YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
MULTIPLE PARTIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THAT REPRESENT TRANSPORT
AND NON TRANSPORT FIRE AGENCIES
. PART THE READINESS AND
RESILIENCY OF FIRING SIMPLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BY HAVING
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE EMAIL IT'S
JUST SITTING. ON THE WALL THE
HOSPITAL'S FOR HOURS AND HOURS.
OF THE DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES
ON THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM. THIS
IS BEEN A LONG STANDING PROBLEM
THIS IS NOT A CO THAT ISSUE
COVERED MAY HAVE EXACERBATED THE
PROBLEM. BUT IS NOT THE CAUSE OF
THE PROBLEM. THERE'S BEEN
STUDIES ON A PART OF THE LAST
DECADE AND ALL OF THEM CONCLUDE
SENATE MORE PROFOUND FOR THE
PROBLEM. BUT THERE ARE SOLUTIONS
OUT THERE TO SOLVE A POT. WE
BELIEVE AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
BEGINS WORKING ON THOSE
SOLUTIONS WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THIS BILL
MOVES THROUGH AND GET THE-
COOPER GUIDANCE FROM AND SO. ON
THE- COMMITTEES OF THE WORKING
ON THREE FOUGHT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE TALKING
TO PEOPLE. THANK YOU TO GUY AND
THEN WE ALSO IN THE ROOM TO TEST
AND PER. CHIEF GARY FOR
SACRAMENTO CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT
. GOOD AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BOB MY
NAME IS GERRY LOS FIRE CHIEF
SACRAMENTO CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY. OF ANYTHING
THAT HELPS US WITH GETTING TO
THE PATIENT AND PATIENT CARE OF
FROM THE HOSPITAL ANYTHING ANY
RESOURCES THEY GO FORWARD- AS
OF. YESTERDAY MORNING OBVIOUSLY
THE TRAGEDY THAT TOOK PLACE HERE
IN THE CITY- I IMMEDIATELY WHEN
I GOT ON SCENE CALLED FOR TEN
MEDIC UNITS- WE WERE FORTUNATE
THAT IT WAS SOME OF OUR OFF PEAK
HOURS YOU CAN JUST IMAGINE IF WE
HAD MEDIC UNITS TIED UP AT THE
HOSPITAL. AND NOT BE ABLE TO GET
THAT THAT CARE TO THOSE-
pTHIS TRAGEDY ALSO WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS- ALSO THE LOSS
OF REVENUE ONE MEDIC UNITS ARE
ON THE WALL. HAVE IS DETRIMENTAL
TO US TRYING TO EXPAND IT
FURTHER IN THE FIRE SERVICE OUT
FOR THE ABILITY TO SERVE THE
CITIZENS OF ALL THE CITIES AND
TOWNS IN CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU
FOR. THANK YOU CHIEF LOACH. SO
AT THIS TIME HELLO CALL FOR
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST OCTOBER'S ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
CONCEPT OF THE PHOTO WORKING ON
AS A FLOCK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE NOBODY ELSE IN THE
ROOM MISTER EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANYBODY IN SUPPORT AND
THOSE THERE IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME THE AGENCY YOU
WORK FOR OR THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT. AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE ORGANIZED- FOR THE BILL AT
THIS TIME. EXPRESS SPORT OVER
THE PHONE FOR SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIR WOULD HAVE NO COMPETENCE
WHICH CAN. ALL RIGHT AT THIS
TIME EVER BUT I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND
DON'T SEE ANY HAVEN'T HEARD ANY
SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM THAT WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION THE BIZ THIS BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD. I THINK WE
HAVE A MOTION BY AGUILAR CURRY
AND I'LL SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON. SO MYSTERY T. AND T.
OPERATOR LET'S GO TO PHONE LINES
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION CAN CALL
IN AT THIS TIME. AND PLEASE AND
ONE ONCE AGAIN YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT. AND
YOUR OPPOSITION. BUT BROUGH
LISTEN BY PHONE PRESS ONE ZERO
WE DO HAVE ONE RESPONDENT THIS
TIME IT BY NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
LINE THIRTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE ONE MORE BEHIND. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS RETURN MEMBERS-
ACTUALLY- AND WITH THAT YOU'RE
WITH THAT CONCERNS PETITIONS THE
COUNTY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. NURSES ASSOCIATION
WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ FOR HIS- WILLINGNESS
TO WORK ON THE STATION FOR
AMBULANCE PATIENT BUT THE WAY
YOU LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERSOF
THE BILL MOVED THROUGH THE
PROCESS. THANK YOU. ALL THANK
YOU THAT'S LINE ONE I DON'T.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SEAN CENTRAL HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE GLOBAL MEDICAL RESPONSE VERY
MUCH IN AGREEMENT THAT MORE NUTS
MUST BE DONE ON THE ISSUE BUT
GMR IS SUPPOSED TO MARK THE
MENDED FOR NOW. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
FUTURE AND- MISTER CHAIR WITH NO
ADDITIONAL RESPONDENTS IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. MISTER AGUILAR CARRY
JUST GOING TO MAKE A COMMENT
THAT'S A LITTLE OFF HERE I WANT
TO THANK- ARE A FIRE. A FIRE
CHIEF IN ALL YOUR STUFF FOR THE
MOST DIFFICULT JOB BEFORE I HAD
TO DO FOR AWHILE. AND THEN I
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION AS WELL AS- TO ALL
YOUR STUFF SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY ANYBODY ELSE. I WILL
ADD A COUPLE COMMENTS TO MR
REYES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND OF WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS ISSUE- OR ALLOWING ME
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS ISSUE
AS PART OF OUR COMMITTEE AND
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN BREWING FOR MANY MANY YEARS
. THIRTY FIVE AND COUNTING AS
FAR AS I AM BY I KNOW- BUT EVERY
ONCE IN AWHILE. ADJUSTMENTS NEED
TO BE MADE IN THE PRE HOSPITAL
CARE SETTING AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND HOW WE'RE DELIVERING
IT. AND HOW WE'RE BEING
EFFECTIVE- BECAUSE TIMES CHANGE.
USE CHANGES POPULATION CHANGES
IN ALL OF THOSE REQUIRE US TO
WORK WITH ALL OF THE- THE-
PARTNERS INVOLVED. IN PROVIDING
BOTH PRE HOSPITAL CARE AND IN
HOSPITAL CARE- AND- THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE TIMES WE CAN'T REALLY
IGNORE IT ANY LONGER. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
ON THESE ISSUES BECAUSE USER
THIS COMPLICATED. IT'S NOT EASY.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE MADE SOME IN
ROADS INTO- RAISING THE
AWARENESS THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS IT NOW. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WITH THAT AND I'M
SECRETARY OF YOU CAN CALL THE
ROLL. IF THE PROMOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ AYE
SERICA AYE CERTO AYE IDEA CREE.
I YEAR CURRY I CALLED JOHN. COLE
JOHN AYE GRAY. WALDRON WALDRON I
WORD FORD I SIX EYES RIGHT THAT
BILL IS ON TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. MR REEVE US WELL MR
RODRIGUEZ RETAKES IS CHAIR ROLE
AND GO AHEAD AND COME ON UP.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR COLLEAGUES ONE OF THANKS
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL
ANALYSIS IN THIS AFTERNOON I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FIVE THREE EIGHT WHICH SEEKS
TO REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
WARNING CENTER WHICH IS A
DIVISION UNDER CAL- YES AND-
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS OUR
STATE. FOR THEM TO COME TOGETHER
TO CREATE A PLAN TO PROVIDE
RESIDENTS- AND OUTDOOR WORKERS A
VOICE AND- TEXT MESSAGE ALERTS
WHEN THE AIR QUALITY REACHES US
AND DANGEROUS LEVELS DUE TO
WILDFIRE SMOKE. SO AS WE KNOW
AMIDST OUR ON GOING AND
WORSENING CLIMATE CRISIS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE CAN
EXPECT TO SEE A 50% INCREASE IN
PARTICLE US AND POLLUTION FROM
WILDFIRE SMOKE BY TWENTY FIFTY.
AND THAT NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO
TRIPLE BY THE END OF THIS
CENTURY. THERE'S NO DENYING THAT
WILDFIRE SMOKE POSES A THREAT TO
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH RECENT STUDIES
AND RESEARCH HAVE LINKED
WILDFIRE SMOKE EXPOSURE TO
CARDIOVASCULAR RESPIRATORY AND
PRENATAL HEALTH IMPACTS. AND AS
WE DISCUSSED IT HIGHLIGHTED JUST
LAST YEAR IN RELATED LEGISLATION
THESE DANGERS ARE ESPECIALLY
TRUE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
FARMWORKERS. THE FARMWORKERS WHO
OFTEN SPEND THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR WORK DAY OUTDOORS DOING
HARD WORK FOR LOW PAY UNDER
CHALLENGING AND DIFFICULT IN AN
OFTEN DANGEROUS SOME CONDITIONS.
IT'S UNDENIABLE THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS COMING OUT FARMWORKERS
FROM MANY DIFFERENT- SOME
DIRECTIONS AT ONCE AND YEAR OVER
YEAR WORSENING EXPOSURE TO
WILDFIRE SMOKE IS MAKING THE
DANGERS THAT THEY ALREADY FACE
EVEN WORSE. ADDITIONALLY MANY
FARMWORKERS THEY DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH OR MANY LACK AWARENESS
OF WHEN THE AIR QUALITY IS
UNSAFE. THIS IS MY FIRST YEAR
HERE IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN I HAVE MADE VERY
CLEAR THAT FARMWORKERS HEALTH
SAFETY AND THEIR DIGNITY MUST BE
AMONG OUR TOP PRIORITIES AS A
STATE. I AND YOU KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS
THEY FILL A DEMAND FOR LATE FOR
AND LABOR IN. AGRICULTURE IT'S
WORK THAT OTHERS JUST DON'T WANT
TO DO- AND THIS LEGISLATION IS
ANOTHER STEP TO ENSURING THAT
WE'RE DOING MORE AS A STATE TO
THAT WOULD DO MORE TO HELP OUR
FARMWORKERS. WOULD DO MORE TO
HELP ALL OUTDOOR WORKERS. AND
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE OF THE
POTENTIAL FOR WILDFIRE SMOKE
EXPOSURE SO THAT THEY CAN DO
WHAT'S NECESSARY TO TAKE THE
APPROPRIATE. PRECAUTIONS A WITH
ME HERE TO TESTIFY ARE- THEN GOT
TO LEAN OUT BEEN TORAH A
FARMWORKERS- THAT IS BASED AT A
FRESNO COUNTY. AS WELL IS THAT
NIGHT I MEAN MARTINEZ DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA- OF THE
CENTRAL- CALIFORNIA BY MUCH OF
THIS NETWORK TO FILL ANY- THE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WITH THAT
THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU SOME
MEMORY WAS OPERATED WE HAVE THE
WITNESSES ON THE LINE. WE HAVE
CATALINA VENTURA AND SLOGANS A
WITNESS YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AS RETURNING YOUR. I
YES GRANTED WHEN I SEVENTH SIFI
LAW IF THEY OF MY LOTUS BACK IN
THE CITY RATHER LATE AND THE
FORMER ARE NUMBING NUMBER OF
COMPANY NOT AND DO NOT. TIMOTHY
JOHN SIX THIRTY IN. OKAY MY
NUMBER NUMBER EVENTY NOT BEEN
BUILT ON VERAGE WHAT CAMPUS
KNOW IT BUT I HAVE NOT ABLE AND
THEY MIGHT THAT MAIN DANIELS AND
THEN COMBO IN THE NUMBER THEY
LIVE I GUESS AND THAT BAND TOLD
BLACK MOST OVER ONLY ONCE SHE
LED. EN LAS LTIMAS LOOKS FINE
YOU KNOW AND MAYBE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT I'M NOT BUT WE MUST BE
INCENTIVES FOR THIS BALANCE OF
MUMBAI NEXT SEPTEMBER BUT IT'S
AND I WOULD LIKE HE CIRCLE YEAH
BURKE ADEQUATE ONLY BE CARE THAT
I THINK THAT A LOT OVER ONE
RENDON CENTER HIS AND LOCAL MOST
OF THEM BE IN. EASY ONE ARE BOTH
LOWER LASHLINE BECAUSE THEY OF
THE NOW- YEAH NOT SAYING FAST
THAT THE EATING. I'M NOT EVEN IN
THE MOST THAT IS THE WILL BE
MORE GET BACK BEHIND THE PRODUCT
. AROUND EIGHT BATTLE I'M- NSAA
MORE MENTAL MEAN AND HELLO I OF
DATA. TO MORTARBOARD. EMAIL A-
YOU SEE. AB STATE. I THANK YOUNG
THOUGH THEY THEY LOOK WILL MORE
THAN. HE CARES BANKS. IS PRETTY
BAD BUT ON A LITTLE- BUT I'LL
HAVE ORDER THAT CAMPBELL.
AIRPORT GAVE.
IF THE DENTAL HOSPITAL STATE
EMPLOYEE AND SOMEONE COMMENSAL
BUT I DO THAT BOTH IN CALIFORNIA
I'M A **** ACT. I GIVE THEM A
SIMPLE MODELS ARE BACK ON THE
LAKE IN IT BUT A- ESTE- IF
THEY'RE MILES EACH WAY. I'M ALSO
LOOKING COMBAT. NUMBER YOUR THAT
IS. VOCAL ARE WHAT J.
COMPARTMENTS ARE NAY. IF BY MOST
OF A HAND DOLAN. A I LIKE IT A
LEAVING AND CONGRESS A LOOK IN
LOS ANGELES OR LOCATED LOOKING
UP IN THE FRONT. YOUR AVAILABLE
THAT FOLLOWED ME FROM ADULT A
HAVE A THAT NAM BOOK LOOK AT
GETTING MORE FIFTY- SAP WHERE
THEY PUT BUT YET BUT A-
GUILLEMETTE HOARDING CAME. YEAH
MORE FOR MY- A GIFT THERE UNLESS
THE ALL- YOU CAN'T TAKE IT FOR
THE MOSTLY IN GIVE. AND THEN.
YEAH KIDDING- ALSO. WANT TO
DON'T HAVE LOTUS. SOMEWHAT OF
WHAT CAN YOU PROBLEM MOST THE
ONCE YOU HAVE A TO STAY CALM IN
GENERAL BY NO. BAD AT ALL THANK
WILL COMBINE OFF CAN INDIA THEN
UNLESS BY YOUNG YEAH SALOME'S.
THREE SUPPORT. AND ON NOTIFIED
YEP MONTROSE WE THE S. TO MY-
AND LESLIE MOM BUT I CAN I CAN.
A BUT I GUESS WHAT I'M BATTLES
HE WILL HAVE A FRONT PORCH
TOMORROW. YET KATE COMMON. FIVE
AM THAN BACK AND FORTH ON THE
HOMEOWNER. SENATE CAMPBELL KNOWS
. THE WHOLE CARE MOST. HELLO
THIS IS IN SEATTLE LANDED UP ON
THEM YOU LOOK AGAIN M. OF IS. IT
WAS BETTER WITH MOST. BUT THEY
HAVE THE SALUTE BUT I KEPT WITH
BUT I MUST SAY THAT OF A HANDLE
. AND DON'T FIT WHAT HE IS
SAYING ME BY LABARAN HE WANTS
AFGHANISTAN OR WILL CHAD MAYES
BATTLE COULD NOT MAKE WHEN.
ESTATE AT THE FINAL TAKE YOUR
LET NIGHT. YES YES.
THE WITNESS STARTS AEROSMITH OF
A PLAYER ONE OPEN YOU PRIVILEGED
. THE SHARE SECRETIVE RESPONSE
ON THE- HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE HEAR. THANK YOU- MEMBERS
OF THEIR FAMILY MY NAME IS MY
NAME IN MY **** I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER FOR NUMBER MEANT THAT
JUSTICE NETWORK AND- YES RIGHT
TO RATING THE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL DEFINITELY WILL HELP
IMPROVE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH ALL
POLL CALIFORNIANS BUT AT THE WAS
STATED BY MS GOT THIRTY NOT INTO
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BILL LOOKS FO WORK BUT ALSO
AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE SPECIAL
COLOR PROVISIONS FOR
FARMWORKERS. WHY I'M NOT READY
FOR I SMOKE EPISODES OUT BECAUSE
THEY ARE WORKING NOT ONLY FOR A
COUPLE OF HOURS BUT FOR AN
ENTIRE DAY WE ARE VERY THANKFUL
FOR- THAT LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVISED FOR INTRODUCED IN
DETAIL I'M GONNA LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING- WHAT- THE STAFF TO MAKE
CHANGES BUT FOR NOW PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AGAIN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE
BODY I READ IN THE HAD BEEN
IMPACTED BY BY OUT WILDFIRES
HEAVILY AND DIALOGUE ABOUTWERE
MADE ECONOMIC INDUSTRY IS THAT-
RELATES TO AGRICULTURE SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPOSED TO WILDFIRES. IN OUR
REGION THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. SO WITHOUT GO TO THE
ROOM ANY IN THE FOR SOME OF AB
TWO FIVE THREE EIGHT. SINAN IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE WHO
LIKES BECAUSE SUPPORTER. AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
OPERATOR. FOR SUPPORT BY PHONE
TWENTY FIVE PER VEHICLES. ONE
ZERO SIX. I WILL GO FIRST TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN ONE ONE
THREE ONE MOM. I'M THIRTEEN IS
LET HAS DROPPED IF YOU. ARE A
LINE FORTY SEVEN SQUARE. I WOULD
OPEN A COMMENT ON EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR NINETEEN I FEEL LIKE I'VE
CALLED AROUND NUMBER. WRONG UP.
FIVE EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ACTUALLY
INTERPRETING FOR MISSED OUT THAT
HE'S GOT BILLION OF INTERNET.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE'RE HERE.
THANK YOU- MISSPELLING OF
INTERNET COMMENT WITH YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GOT THE
LINO VENTURA FROM FRESNO COUNTY
I AM IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
PROPOSAL. TO PROTECT FARMWORKERS
WHO ARE WORKING OUT IN THE FIELD
I HAVE WORKED IN THE FIELDS
PICKING PEACHES- CHILIES OLIVES
AND I REMEMBERD THAT I WE HAD A
REALLY DIFFICULT TIME WHERE WE
WERE OUT WORKING IN THE FIELD
AND WE COULDN'T EVEN SEE AND
THERE WERE ACTIONS ALL VER THE
LEAVES AND YET WE WERE HAVING TO
WORK UNDER THESE CONDITIONS THEN
MY CHEST STARTED HURTING- FROM
INHALING THE SMOKE. EIGHTY IT'S
A SAD SITUATION THAT WE THE
FARMWORKERS HAVE TO- INJURY THE
SITUATION WE COULD PICK THE
VEGETABLES THAT GO TO YOUR HEAD
AND THE FRUITS THAT GO TO YOUR
TABLE AND THIS- LAW THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED TODAY IS A GOOD
START AND IT WILL HELP US
FARMWORKERS BECAUSE WE ARE THE
WE ARE THE ONES WORKING ALL THE
TIME- UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND WE NEED CLEAN AIR I AM.
PLEASED TO ALL. OF OUR
FARMWORKERS OUT THERE. TODAY AND
THE- WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE IN. IS THAT THEY- IN A
WAY THAT WE CAN READ AND
UNDERSTAND- I AM FROM HOW CAN I
SPEAK MYSTICAL AND OFTENTIMES I
EVEN- WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE INFORMATION EVEN
AFTER PROVIDED IN SPANISH IT
ALSO NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED. IN
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES. ARE WE
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT WE ARE
INTENTIONAL SO TODAY I AM HERE
TO ASK THAT- YOU PROTECT US AND
I HOPE THAT YOU TAKE- MY ACCOUNT
INTO CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT ON THE ON THE LINE.
WE HAVE QUITE A FEW MISTER CHAIR
NEXT TO BE LINED NUMBER FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOU'VE QUEUED UP TO-
TO SUPPORT MY PHONE FOR TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT MILLION LINES
OPEN. WILL BE ON THE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY TO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
GABRIELLA THANK YOUR CALLING OUT
OF THE COMMUNITY RESIDENCES KERN
COUNTY BAKERSFIELD AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT. WITH THE
AMENDMENT. TO ASK SUPPORT FROM
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR
MEMBERS WE ONE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
. ONE TWENTY ONE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SALLY
RATHER- I'M CALLING IN AS A
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS FROM
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT SUPPORT OF
ARAMARK BURKE COMMUNITY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE ARE NEXT TO MY
NUMBER. FORTY EIGHT ONE FORTY
SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS ANTHONY
AND I'M CALLING ON THE PRESIDENT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENT THE COURT APARTMENT
UNITY. NEXT UP IS MY NUMBER
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES CORRECT. THANK YOU HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME EARNERS AND
I'M CALLING IN ON THE COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS FROM CENTRAL VALLEY
AND OF COURSE AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT AM THE AMENDMENT
THAT WHAT THE FOR OUR
FARMWORKERS MEETING. THANK YOU.
NEXUS COIN THIRTEENTH IS GOING
pCAL CAN THE CALIFORNIA QUITE
MANY OTHER CULTURES THAT WORK
HERE A COLLECTION OF THE THING
OF ALL AN ORGANIC FARMING
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TO ENSURE
THE RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA
FARMS AND RANCHES THE CLIMATE
CHANGE. WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT AND THE PART
BE BECAUSE THE VISION FOR THE
BILL TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION. FOR
FARMWORKERS. THANK YOU. AND A
STRUGGLING NUMBER TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME THE
OTHER LENDERS NO I'M THE FRESNO
COUNTY RESIDENT AND A DAUGHTER
OF A FORMER CARE AND SUPPORT.
EIGHTY FIVE THREE EIGHT. MISTER
CHAIR WITH THAT THE KEY WAS NOT
CLEAR. THANK YOU WITH THAT
DESERVE ANYONE IN THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION. SAY NOT OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. A TO VOICE
OPPOSITION BY PHONE ON AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT PRESS ONE ZERO
PLEASE. MISTER CAN HAVE NO
RIGNALL FONG EXPONENTS IN
KYRGYZSTAN CHAIR- COOPER BRING
BACK TO MEMBERS ANY MEMBERS
COMING ANY QUESTIONS. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND BY THE
CURRENT. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS LIKE TO A
CLOSE THIS RESPECT LAST BUT I
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
WOULD YOU HAVE A- MOTION AND A
SECOND-THE MOTION TO PASTOR
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVER SPRINGS BEFORE TO PROTECT
OUR FARMWORKERS SO WITH THAT US
SECRETARY CALDERON. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ RIGHT
ARE YOU GUYS I SAT DOWN HI SIR
TELL AYE AYE YEAR CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I CALLED JOHN HI
CALL JOHN I. GREAT HI GREAT I
WALDRON. WALDRON I WARD. FORD I
SEVEN NICE THE MOTION IS OUT. SO
THAT THE SECTOR GO BACK TO THE
TOP LINE TO CALL ANY MISSION
MEMBERS OF OR THE FIRST ONE. R.
A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY EIGHT
MAIENSCHEIN. GREAT HI GREAT I
FORD FORD I. WHICH ONE AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE CALL THE
MACHINE MEMBERS. OKAY HI OKAY I.
THINK THE NEXT ONE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY RODRIGUEZ GREAT HI OKAY
I. NEXT ONE AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT. WE GOT EVERYBODY
OUT. BUT AFTER AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN COOLEY OKAY. I GRAY AYE
FORD FORD I. AND NOW ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY FOUR GABRIEL IN AB
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR RODRIGUEZ
OKAY HI I BOARD. FORTY FIVE.
WITH THAT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.